I think you should really connect with
Boyd Boyd is definitely gonna be what I
would call my pipe to the hip-hop music
world
[Music]
Monday morning my butt distribution got
it and that should be on you and you can
jam with us and I'll try to help
distribution of course music I'm gonna
people to hear it one one thing I'm
really good at is knowing what like
normal Americans that aren't into music
will like because I'm actually that I'm
not a good I'm not a very good music
person huh I'm being serious
like I know that for a fact boy do I
really understand America so I know
Billy Williams like I know that's a hit
I'm always right about that [ __ ]
so like get that [ __ ] song out I know
it I just know it because I'm that
person
I'm not Boyd who really knows music I'm
being serious
do you understand like I don't know when
people like oh that artists is nothing
like I don't understand
I know hits I just know that like normal
people
correct 17 year old Sally and Arkansas
like oh that like that song there's a
lot of songs that people aren't like
like when I listen to 21 savages album
like there's two songs that I know Sally
will like this always happens right like
I'm like this is back to me not being
good music I it was crazy how much more
I understood it the second time I
listened that first the first time this
would always happen the music listening
is that what always happened to music
was it with you yeah it was correct the
first time I was like me I was so
excited and second I'm like I understand
every word
I don't do that at all now I'm getting a
little bit more into like now like now
like what's interesting is like so much
it like is coming to me too and so I'm
trying to figure out how I'm gonna do it
actually on his show cuz if I get a show
I got put on and it literally was all
based on hip-hop thesis my brain was
like okay when new rappers show up but
like Kendrick Lamar built his career I'm
like you get like like so smartly I'm
like just try like his best work was
always when he was guest appearing he
tried to bring his hardest game because
he's like I'm and if I can take your
fans like soon that's where I listen to
him on like in the early days I'm like
that's what he's doing because I
understand it that's why I'm always
working and getting on shows and doing
podcasts I'm like I'm [ __ ] that's why
I do it I'm like come come and take your
fans so life so that's what I want you
to start thinking like as a businessman
marketer for him and you to of where can
you go where it's perceived as you're
giving them value keeps they're giving
them a song but what you're doing is
getting way more audience yeah like ASAP
you should look at all the apps all the
gaming apps anything popping that feels
authentic you want to be on lollipop
challenge or maybe well maybe you do
maybe you do you guys know that I don't
know that but I would [ __ ]
straight-up go to the App Store look at
the top hundred games game number 77 and
just [ __ ] UAL them and be like I
represent one of the best up-and-coming
artists we want to give you the song
rights this because we love your game
and like get it
integrated into your the next game yeah
Madden everything I know I know from
watching it in different generations
Good Charlotte on Madden Snoop aundre's
album so
cool honestly I think that 24/7 out
understatement to my day today ain't no
way that I'm gonna make away anyways I
never listen kept Amanda [ __ ] this is
for the ones who ain't a friend and it's
this morning's paper she's our new look